the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's continue talking
about maximum likelihood estimation in
the context of generalized linear models
all right so in those generalized linear
models what we spend most of the past
lectures working on is the conditional
distribution of Y so we have Y given X
and we're going to assume that this
follows some distribution in the
exponential family ok and so what it
means is that if I look at the density
say or the PMF but let's talk about
densities to make things clear we're
going to assume that Y given F X as the
distribution so X is now fixed because
we're conditioning on it and has a
density which is of this form of Y I Phi
ok so to see again we don't really need
to think about it this is something
that's gonna come out naturally as soon
as you need a normalization factor and
so here what it means so if this is the
distribution of Y given X I so that's
the density of Y I given X is equal to
little X I so if it's the conditional
distribution of Y
I give an X I it should depend on X I
somehow and it does not appear to depend
on X I and here the model is gonna be on
theta I which is just a function theta I
of X I and we're gonna take a very
specific one it's going to be a function
of a linear a linear form of the X I so
really we're gonna take something which
is of the form theta I which is really
just as theta does not depend on X sine
of X I transpose some beta okay so all
this parts here this is really some
modeling assumptions that we're making
and once we've agreed on what
distribution we want okay so to do that
so our goal of course is going to try to
understand what this beta is there's one
beta here what's important is that this
beta does not depend on I so if I
observe pairs X I Y I let's say I
observe n of them I equals 1 to n the
hope is that as I accumulate more and
more pairs of this form where there's
always the same parameter that links x
i2 y I that's this parameter beta then I
should have a better and better
estimation of this beta because it's
always the same and that's essentially
what couples all of our distribution if
I did not assume this then I could have
a different distribution for each pair X
i given Y I and I would not be able to
do any statistics that with nothing
nothing would average in the end but
here I have the same beta which means
that I can hope to do statistics on
average errors that okay so I'm gonna
collect two I'll come back to this so
but as usual in the linear regression
model we're gonna collect all our
observations Y I so here I'm going to
assume that they're real valued and that
my x i's are valid takes value in our p
just like in the regression model and
I'm gonna collect all my Y eyes into one
big vector Y in RN and all my X's into
one big matrix in our n times P okay
just like for the linear regression
model
alright so again what I'm interested in
here is the conditional distribution of
Y i given X I okay and I said this is
this distribution when we're talking
about regression I defined last time
what the definition of a regression
function was it's just one particular
aspect of this conditional distribution
is the conditional expectation of Y
given X I okay and so this conditional
expectation I will denote it by so I
shall talk about the conditional so
that's I'm gonna call it's a new I which
is the conditional expectation of Y i
given X item little X I say you can
forget about this part if you find it
confusing it really doesn't matter it's
just so that this is just this means
that this is a function of little X i
but if I only had expectation of Y I
given big X I this would be just a
function of B X I all right so it really
doesn't change anything it's just a
matter of notation okay so just forget
about this part but I'll just do it like
that here okay so this is just the
conditional expectation of y given x i
alright it just depends on X I so
particularly depends on I and so I will
call it new I but I know that since I'm
in a canonical exponential family then I
know that new I is actually B prime of
theta I okay so there's a one-to-one
link between the canonical parameter of
my exponential family and the mean mu I
the conditional expectation and the
modeling assumptions we're going to make
is not directly that's we remember that
was the second aspect of the generalized
linear model we're not going to assume
that theta I itself directly depends on
X I we're going to assume that mu I has
a particular dependence on X I through
the link function all right so again
we're back to modeling so we have a link
function G
and we assume that UI depends on X I as
follows G of MU I and remember G all G
does for us is really map the space in
which new I lives which could be just
interval 0 1 so the entire real line
alright and we're gonna assume that this
thing that lives in the real line is
just X I transpose beta I should put a
small X I transpose beta ok
so we're making indeed some modeling
assumption but compared to in the linear
regression model we only assume that mu
I was X I transpose beta so if you want
to make a parallel between generalized
linear models and linear model it's just
the only difference is that G is not the
identity necessarily in this case and
all the G does for us is to just make
this thing compatible that those two
things on the left and the right of this
equality live in the same same space so
in a way we're not making a much you
know bigger leap of faith by assuming a
linear model the linear link is already
here we're just making things compatible
all right and so this is gonna be what
so it's always the same link function so
now if I want to go back to beta right
because I'm going to want to express my
likelihood right so if I were to express
my likelihood from this it would just be
a function of theta right and so if I
want to maximize my likelihood I don't
want to maximize an integer I want to
maximize it in beta so if I can write my
density as a function of beta then I
will be able to write my likelihood as a
function of beta and then talk about my
maximum likelihood estimator and so all
I need to do is to just say okay how do
I replace theta by what is I know that
theta is a function of beta right I
wrote it here so the question is what
what is this function and I actually
have access to all of this so what I
know is that they
right so mu is B prime of theta which
means that theta I is D prime inverse of
MU I okay so that's what we got from
this you know derivative of the log
likelihood equal to zero
that gave us this guy inverted and now I
know that nu I is G inverse of X I beta
so this composition of B prime inverse
and G inverse is actually just the
composition of G with B Prime
everybody's comfortable with this
notation the little circle my question
about this alright just means that I
first apply D Prime
well actually it's the inverse but if I
look at a function G composed with B
prime I first applied G G B prime of X
is just G of B prime of X okay and then
I take the inverse of this function
which is first take G inverse and then
take D prime inverse okay so now I have
everywhere I saw theta now I see this
function of beta so I could technically
plug that in of course it's a little
painful to have to write G circle beta
prime all the time so I'm gonna give
this guy a name and so you're just gonna
define H which is G B prime inverse so
that theta I is simply H of X I
transpose beta okay I could give it a
name you know let's call but let's just
call it that all the H function
so there isn't something which is nice
about this h function is that if G is
the canonical link what is the canonical
link right so it's what is it canonical
to a canonical link its canonical to a
particular distribution in the
expression on achill exponential family
right a canonical exponential family is
completely characterized by the function
B which means that if I want to talk
about the canonical link all I need to
tell you is how it depends on B so what
is G as a function of B what B inverse D
prime inverse right so this is G is
equal to B prime inverse which means
that if G is composed with B prime that
means that this is just the identity so
H is the identity so H of X I transpose
beta is simply X I transpose V and it's
true that the way we introduce the
canonical link was just the function for
which we model directly theta I as X I
transpose beta right which is we can
read off here right so theta I is simply
X I transpose beta so now for example if
I go back to this to my Lord likelihood
which I know so if I go back to my log
likelihood right so if I look log
likelihood so the log likelihood is sum
of the log of the densities so it's sum
from I could want un a vlog
exponential why I theta I minus B theta
I divided by Phi plus C of Y I Phi all
right so this term that does not depend
on theta so I have two things first of
all the log and they explain the
exponential are gonna cancel each other
and ii actually know that theta is just
a function of beta and it has this form
theta I is H of X I transpose beta and
that's my modeling assumption so this is
actually equal to the sum from I equal 1
to N of Y I and then here I'm going to
write H of X I transpose beta minus B of
H of X I transpose beta divided by Phi
and then I have again this function C of
yi5 which again won't matter because
when I'm gonna try to maximize this
thing this is just playing the role of a
constant that's shifting the entire
function so in particular the org max is
gonna be exactly what it was ok so this
thing is really not gonna matter for me
I'm keeping track of it and actually if
you look here it's going right it's gone
because it does not matter so let's just
pretend it's not here
because it won't matter and what I'm
trying to maximize the likelihood ok
well it's here up to a constant term it
says that's the constant term all right
any question all I'm doing here is
replacing my likelihood as a function of
theta eyes so if I had one theta I per
observation again this would not help me
very much but if I assume that they're
all linked together by saying that theta
I is of the form X I transpose beta
where H of X I transpose beta if I'm not
using the care they can occur linked
then I can hope to make some estimation
all right so again if I have the
canonical link H is the identity so I'm
left only
with weii times X I transpose beta and
then I have B of X I transpose beta and
not be composed with H because H is the
identity which is fairly simple right
why is it simple well let's actually
focus on this guy for one second so let
me write it down so we know what we're
talking about so we just showed that the
log likelihood when I use the canonical
link so that H is equal to the identity
the log likelihood actually takes the
form Ln and it depends on a bunch of
stuff but let's just make it depend only
on the parameter that we care about
which is beta all right so this is of
the form alpha beta and that's equal to
what is the sum from I could 1 to N of
why I X I transpose beta minus let me
put the Phi here and then I'm gonna have
minus B of X I transpose beta okay and C
we know is some known positive term so
again optimizing a function plus some
constant or optimizing a function times
a constant that's not gonna change much
either so it won't really matter to
think about whether this Phi is here or
not but let's just think about what this
function looks like all right I'm trying
to maximize a function I'm trying to
maximize the log likelihood if it looked
like this I would be a serious problem
but we can do like it basic you know
back up the envelope guess of what the
variations of this function is this
first term here is as a function of beta
it's what kind of function is it it's
linear right this is just X I transpose
beta if I multiply beta by 2 I get twice
if I add something to beta
it just gets added so it's a linear
function of beta and so this thing is
both convex and concave in the one
dimensional case so think about P as
being one dimensional so that beta is
dimensional thing those are just the
function that looked like this right
those are linear functions they are both
convex and concave so this is not gonna
matter when it comes to the convexity of
my overall function because I'm just
adding something which is just a line
and so if I started with convex is gonna
stay convex first area with concave is
gonna stay concave and if I started with
something which is both is gonna stay
both meaning neither cannot people ah
yeah so if you're neither convex or
concave adding this linear so this will
not really matter if I want to
understand what my function looks like I
need to understand what B of X I
transpose beta does again the X I
transpose beta no impact it's a linear
function in terms of convexity it's not
gonna play any role so I really need to
understand what my function B looks like
what do we know about B again so we know
that D prime of theta is equal to MU
right well you know the mean of a random
variable and economical exponential
family can be a positive or a negative
number this really does not tell me
anything that can be really anything
however if I look at the second
derivative of B I know that this is what
this is the variance of Y divided by
five right that was my dispersion
parameter the variance was equal to five
times B prime prime so we know that if
theta is not degenerate meaning that you
know the density does not take value
infinity at only one point
this thing is actually positive and
clearly when you have something that
looks like this and unless you have some
crazy stuff happening with Phi being
equal to zero or anything that's not
normal
then you will see that you're not
degenerate so this thing is strictly
positive and we've said several time
that if B prime prime is positive then
that means that you know that's the
derivative of B prime meaning that B
prime is increasing and B prime is
increasing is just the same thing as
saying that B is convex right so that
implies that B
strictly convex and the strictly means
comes from the fact that this is a
strict fine all right so it's just a
strict sign meaning that the function
this is not strictly convex because it's
linear
shrevie convex means there's always some
curvature everywhere
so now I have this thing that's linear
minus something that's convex something
that's negative something convex is
concave so this thing is linear plus
concave so it is concave so I know just
by looking at this that Ln of be de
which of course is something that lives
in our P but if I saw it living in our
one it would look like this and if I saw
living it in our two it would look like
it don't like this and it the fact that
it strict is also telling me that
there's actually unique money Maximizer
so there's unique Maximizer in X I
transpose beta but not in beta
necessarily we're gonna need it extra
assumptions for this okay so this is
what I say here the log likelihood is
strictly concave and so as the
consequence under extra assumptions on
the excise because of course if the
excise are not if the excise are all the
same right so that like if the entries
of X is so if X I is equal to 1 1 1 1 1
then X I transpose beta is just the sum
of the betas and I will be of the beta
eyes I will be strictly concave in those
guys but certainly not in the individual
entries ok so I need extra thing on my X
I so that this happens just like we
needed the matrix capital X in the
linear regression case to be full rank
so we could actually identify what beta
was okay it's gonna be exactly the same
thing so so here this is when we have
this very specific parameterization and
the question is but it might not be the
case if we change the parameter beta
into something else okay so here the
fact that we use the canonical link and
etc everything actually works really to
our advantage
all right so that everything becomes
strictly concave and we know exactly
what's happening
all right so I understand I went a bit
fast on playing with convex and concave
function this is not the purpose you
know I could spend a lecture telling you
oh if I add two concave functions then
the result remains concave if I had a
you know concave and a strictly concave
then the result still remains strictly
concave and we could spend time proving
this this is what's just for you to get
an intuition as to why this is correct
but we don't really have time to go into
too much details one thing you can do
trifa concave function if it's in one
dimension all I need to have is that the
second derivative is strictly a strictly
negative right that's a strictly concave
function that was the analytic
definition we had four straight
concavity so if this was in one
dimension it would look like this why I
times X I times beta now beta is just
one number and then I would have minus
beta X I times B and this is all over
five you take second derivatives the
fact that this is linear in beta this is
gonna go away and here I'm just going to
be left with minus so if I take the
second derivative with respect to beta
this is going to be equal to minus B
prime prime X I beta times X I squared
divided by Phi so this is clearly
positive that's that's where if X I is 0
this is the generate so I would not get
it then I have the second derivative of
B prime which I know is positive because
of the variance thing that I have here
divided by Phi and so that would all be
fine that's for one dimension if I
wanted to do this in higher dimensions
and we have to say that the Hessian is a
positive definite matrix and that's
maybe a bit beyond what this course is
okay
so in the rest of this chapter I will do
what I did not do when we talked about
maximum likelihood and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna actually show how to
do this maximization right so here we
know that the function is concave but
what it looks like
specifically depends on what B is and
for different B's I'm gonna have
different things to do just like when I
was talking about maximum likelihood
estimation if I had a concave log
likelihood function I could optimize it
but depending on what the function is
I would actually need some algorithms
that's maybe working better on some
functions than others now here I don't
have random things I have the B is the
cumulant generating function of a
canonical exponential family and there
is a way for me to sort of leverage that
alright so not only is the there's the
the B part but there's also the linear
part and if I start trying to use that
I'm actually going to be able to devise
very specific optimization algorithms
and the way I'm going to be able to do
this is by thinking of simple blackbox
optimization to which I can actually
technically feed any function but it's
going to turn out that the iterations of
this iterative algorithms are gonna look
very familiar when we when we just plug
in the particular values of B of the log
likelihood that we have for this problem
and so the three methods we're gonna
talk about going from more blackbox
meaning you can basically stuff at any
function it's gonna work any concave
function it's gonna work all the way to
this is working specifically for
generalized linear models our newton
raphson method who's already heard about
the newton raphson method right so you
know any that's probably some people
actually learn this algorithm without
even knowing the word algorithm right
it's a function that I mean typically
it's supposed to be finding roots of
functions but finding the root of a
function of the derivative is the same
as finding the minimum of a function so
that's the first black box method I mean
it's it's it's pretty old and then
there's something that's very specific
to what we're doing which is called so
this newton-raphson method is going to
the Hessian of our log-likelihood and
since we know something about the
Hessian for a particular problem we're
gonna be able to move on to Fisher
scoring and the word Fisher here is
actually exactly coming from Fisher
information so the Hessian is gonna
involve the Fisher information and
finally we will talk about iteratively
re-weighted least squares and that's not
for any function it's really when we're
trying to use the fact that there is
this linear dependence on the x i's and
this is essentially gonna tell us well
you know you can use least squares for
linear regression here you can use least
squares but locally and you have to
iterate okay and this last part is
essentially a trick by statisticians to
be able to solve the newton-raphson
updates without actually having a
dedicated software for this but just
being able to reuse some least squares
software okay so you know we've talked
about this many times I just want to
make sure that we're all on the same
page here we have a function f we're
going to assume that it has two
derivatives and it's a function from RM
to R so it's first derivative is called
gradient that's just a vector that
collects all the partial derivatives
with respect to each of the coordinates
it's dimension M of course and the
second derivative is an M by M matrix
it's called the Hessian and on the I J
on the I throw and J column you see the
second partial derivative with respect
to the iced component and the J
component okay we've seen that several
times this is just multivariable
calculus but really the point here is to
us maybe the notation is slightly
different because I want to keep track
of F so when I write the gradient I
write nabla sub F and well and when I
write the Hessian I write nabla sub H
sub F and if as I said if F is strictly
concave then H f of X is negative
definite what it means is that if I take
any X in R M then X transpose H f
well that's for any X 0 X this is
actually strictly negative that's what
it means to be negative definite okay so
every time I do X transposed to be fair
so this is like a quadratic form and I
want it to be negative for all values of
x 0 and X both of them that's very
strong clearly but for us actually this
is what happens just because of the
properties of P well at least the fact
that it's an negative less than or equal
to if I want it to be strictly less I
need some properties on X and then I
will call the Hessian map the function
that map's X to this matrix h f of X ok
so that's just a second derivative F at
X yeah where do I say smooth oh yeah I
mean you know you need to be able to
apply for slamming let's say yes to
continuous derivative that's smooth
okay so how does the newton-raphson
method work well what it does is that it
forms a quadratic approximation to your
function and that's the one it optimizes
at every single point okay and the
reason is because we have a closed form
solution to the finding the minimum of a
quadratic function so if I give you a
function that's of the form ax squared
plus B X plus C you know exactly a
closed form for its minimum and but if I
give you any function or let's say yeah
yeah so here it's all about maxima I'm
sorry I'm gonna try to if you're
confused with me using the word minimum
just assume that it was the word maximum
so this is how it works okay if I give
you a function which is concave and
that's quadratic okay so it's gonna look
like this alright so that's of the form
ax squared where a is negative of course
plus BX plus C then you know you can
solve your whatever you can take the
derivative of this guy set it equal to
zero and you will have an exact equation
into what the value of x is that it
realizes this maximum if I give you any
function that's concave that's not clear
right I mean you know if I tell you the
function that we have here is of the
form ax minus B of X right then I'm just
gonna have something that inverts B
prime but you know how do I do it
exactly it's not clear and so what we do
is we do a quadratic approximation which
should be true approximately everywhere
right so we find that this point here
I'm gonna say oh I'm close to being that
function and if I'm at this point here
I'm gonna be close to being that
function and for this functions I can
actually optimize and so if I'm not
moving too far from one to the other I
should actually get something so here's
how the quadratic approximation works
I'm gonna write the second-order Taylor
expansion
okay and so that's just gonna be my
quadratic approximation is gonna say Oh
f of X when X is close to some point x0
is gonna be close to F of x0 plus the
gradient of F at x0 transpose X minus x0
and then I'm gonna have plus 1/2 X minus
x0 transpose H F at x0 X minus X
transpose right X minus x0 so that's
just my second-order Taylor expansion
multivariate one and that's let's say x0
is this guy now what I'm gonna do is say
okay if I wanted to set this the
derivative of this guy equal to zero I
would just have to solve well you know f
prime of x equals zero meaning that X
has to be F prime inverse of zero and
really apart from like being some
notation manipulation this is really not
helping me okay because I don't know
what F prime inverse of 0 is in many
instances however if F has a very
specific form which is something that
depends on X in a very specific way
there's just a linear term in the new
kinetic term then I can actually do
something all right so let's forget
about this approach and rather than
minimizing F let's just minimize the
right hand side okay so sorry maximize
so maximize the right hand side and so
how do I get this well I just set the
gradient equal to zero so what is the
gradient the first term does not depend
on X okay so that means that this is
going to be zero plus what is the
gradient of this thing of the gradient
of F at x0 transpose X minus x0 what is
the gradient of this guy
so I have a function of the form B
transpose X what is the gradient of this
thing
I'm sorry I'm writing everything in two
column form right so it's just B okay so
here what is B well its gradient of F at
x0 okay and this term here gradient of F
at x0 transpose X 0 is just the constant
this thing is going away as well and
then I'm looking at the derivative of
this guy here and this is like a
quadratic term it's like H times X minus
x0 squared so when I'm gonna take the
derivative I'm gonna have a factor 2
that's gonna pop out and cancel this 1/2
and then I'm gonna be left only with
this part times this part okay so that's
plus h F X minus x0 okay so that's just
gradient and I want it to be equal to 0
so I'm just gonna solve this equal to 0
okay so now it means that if I want to
find the minimum this is going to be the
X star that satisfies this so that's
actually equivalent to H F times X star
is equal to H F x0 minus gradient F at
x0 now this is a much easier thing to
solve what is this this is just a system
of linear equations right I just need to
find the x star such that when I pre
multiply it by a matrix I get this
vector on the right hand side this is
just something of the form ax equals B
and have many ways I can do this I could
do Gaussian elimination or I could use
you though Spillman's
faster laplacian solvers if I had some
particular properties of H I mean
there's huge activity in terms of how to
solve those systems
but let's say I don't I have some time
it's not a huge problem I can actually
just use linear algebra and then your
algebra just tells me that X star is
equal to HF inverse times this guy which
those two guys are gonna cancel so this
actually equal to x0 minus H F inverse
gradient F at x0 and that's just what's
called a Newton iteration so I started
at some x0 I met some x0 where I make my
approximation and it's telling me if
starting from this x0
I wanted to fully optimize Ecstatic
approximation I would just have to take
the X star that's this guy and then I
could just use this guy as my x0 and do
it again and again and again and again
and those are called Newton iterations
and they're basically the working horse
the workhorse of of you know interior
point methods for example a lot of
optimization algorithms and that's what
you can you see here X star is equal to
x0 minus the inverse Hessian times the
gradient we briefly mentioned gradient
descent we briefly mentioned grading
descent right at some point to optimize
a convex function right and if I wanted
to use gradient descent again H is a
matrix but if I wanted to think of H as
being a scalar would it be a positive or
negative number yeah
quiet
yeah so that would be this so I want to
move against the gradient to do what to
minimize but I'm maximizing here right
everything is maximized right so I know
that H is actually negative definite so
it's a negative number okay so that's
you're making the same you have the same
confusions that you we're maximizing a
concave function here so H is negative
so this is something of the form X 0
plus something times the gradient and
this is what your gradient ascent rather
than descent would look like and all
it's saying Newton is telling you don't
take the gradient for granted as a
direction in which you want to go
it says do a slight change of
coordinates before you do this according
to what your Hessian looks like alright
and that's what those are called
second-order methods they require
knowing what the Hessian is but those
are actually much more powerful than the
gradient descent because they're using
all of the local geometry of the problem
all of the local geometry of your
function is completely encoded in this
Hessian and in particular it implies
that it tells you where to switch and
not go slower in some places or go
faster in other places now this in
practice for say modern large-scale
machine learning problems inverting this
matrix H is extremely painful it's it
takes too much time the matrix is too
big and computers cannot do it and
people resort to what's called pseudo
Newton methods which essentially try to
emulate what this guy is and there's
many ways you can do this some of them
is by using gradients that you've
collected in the past some of them is
using the fact that just say well let's
just pretend H is diagonal just there's
a lot of things you can do to just play
around this and not actually have to
invert this matrix ok so once you have
this you started from H 0 it tells you
which H star you can get as Maximizer of
the local quadratic approximation to
your function you can actually just
iterate that all right so you start at
some X 0 somewhere and then once you get
to
some XK you just do the Eurasian which
is described which is just fine a clip
was one which is the Maximizer of the
local quadratic approximation to your
function at XK and repeat until
convergence okay so if this was an
optimization class we would prove that
convergence actually eventually happens
for a strictly concave function this is
a sass class or just gonna have to trust
me that this is the case and it's
globally convergent meaning that you can
start wherever you want and and it's
gonna work and the for under minor
conditions on F in particular those
conditions are satisfied for the
log-likelihood functions we have in mind
okay and it converges at an extremely
fast rate usually it's quadratic
convergence which means that every time
you make one step you improve the
accuracy of your solution by two digits
okay if that's something you're vaguely
interested in I highly recommend that
you take a class on nonlinear
optimization it's a fascinating topic of
unfortunately we don't have much time
but it starts to in being more and more
intertwined with high dimensional
statistics and machine learning
that's about the Phi I mean it's it's an
algorithms class typically but it's very
much maybe more principled it's not a
bunch of algorithms that solve a bunch
of problems there's basically one basic
idea which is if I have a convex
function I can actually minimize it if I
have a conviction concave function I can
maximize it and there's it devolves
around similar things all right so let's
stare at this iterative step for a
second and pause and ask me let me know
if you have any questions okay so of
course in a second we will plug in for
the log likelihood this is just a
general thing for a general function f
but in a second F is going to be LM okay
so if I wanted to implement that for
real I would have to compute the
gradient of Ln at a point XK and I would
have to compute the Hessian at a given
point and then
okay so this is just a basic algorithm
and this as you can tell used in no
place the fact that L n was the log
likelihood associated to some canonical
exponential family in a generalized
linear model all right
this never showed up so can we use that
somehow optimization for the longest
time was about making your problems as
general as possible
simulating maybe in the entry point
method theory and conic programming in
the mid-90s and now what optimization is
doing is that it necessary generalists
is okay if I'm going to start to go fast
I need to exploit as much structure
about my problem as I can and the beauty
is that as statisticians or machine
learning people we do have a bunch of
very specific problem that we want
optimizers to solve and they can make
things run much faster but this did not
require to wait until the 21st century
problem with very specific structure
arose already in the this generalized
linear model so what do we know well we
know that this log likelihood is really
one thing that comes when we're trying
to replace an expectation by an average
and then doing something fancy right
that was our statistical hammer and
remember when we introduced likelihood
maximization we just said what we really
want to do is to minimize the key L
right that's the thing we wanted to
minimize the KL divergence between two
distributions the true one and the one
that's parametrized by some unknown
theta and we're trying to minimize that
over theta and we said well I don't know
what this is because it's an expectation
with respect to some unknown
distribution so let me just replace the
expectation with respect to my unknown
distribution by an average over my data
points and that's how we justified the
existence of the log likelihood
maximization problem but here I actually
I might be able to compute this
expectation at least partially where I
need it and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say okay since at a given point XK
say let me call it here theta I'm trying
to find the inverse of the Hessian of my
log likelihood right so if you look at
the previous one as I said we're gonna
have to compute the
in H sub L n of XK and then invert it
but let's forget about the inversion
step for a second we have to compute the
Hessian this is because we're trying
this is the Hessian of the function
we're trying to minimize but if I could
actually replace it not by the function
I'm trying to minimize to maximize to
read the log likelihood but really by
the function I wish I was actually
maximized minimizing which is the KO
right then that would be really nice and
what happens is that since I'm actually
trying to find this at a given XK I can
always pretend that this XK that I have
in my current iteration is the true one
and compute my expectation with respect
to that guy and what happens is that I
know that when I compute the expectation
of the Hessian of the log-likelihood at
a given theta and when I take the
expectation with respect to the same
theta what I get out is negative Fisher
information right the Fisher information
was defined in two ways as the
expectation of the square of the
derivative or the expectation negative
the expectation of the second derivative
of the log likelihood and so now I'm
doing some sort of a leap of faith here
because this theta there's no way the
theta which is the current XK that's the
current theta at which I'm actually
doing this optimization I'm actually
pretending that this is the right one
but what's going to change by doing this
is that it's gonna make my life easier
because when I take expectations I tend
to have when I will see that when we
look at the Hessian it's so the Hessian
as essentially the derivative of say a
product is going to be the sum of two
terms right the derivative of U times V
is U prime V Plus UV Prime one of those
two terms is actually going to have
expectation 0 and that's gonna make my
life very easy when I take expectations
I'm basically gonna just have one term
that's gonna go away and so in
particular my formula is just by the
virtue of taking this expectation before
inverting the Hessian is gonna just
shrink the size of my formulas by 1/2
okay so let's see
this works you don't have to believe me
is there any question about this slide
you guys remember when we're doing
maximum likelihood estimation and you
know Fisher information in the KL
divergence etc yeah because that's what
we're really trying to minimize mmm yeah
so there's something you need to trust
me with which is that the expectation of
H of L M is actually H of the
expectation of L n all right
yeah it's true right because the
derivative taking derivative is a linear
operator and we actually use that
several times when we said expectation
of second derivative like actually
expectation of partial of L with respect
to theta is equal to zero remember we
did that
it's basically what we use right I still
log likelihood
yeah so actually Ln is typically not
normalized so I really should talk about
L n over N okay but let's see that okay
so if I have iid observations that
should be pretty obvious okay so if I
have iid say thanks 1 xn with density F
theta and if I look at log F theta of X
I sum from I could 1 to n as I said I
need to actually have a 1 over n here
when they look at the expectation they
all have the same expectation right so
this is actually indeed equal to
negative KL plus a constant okay and
negative KL is because this if I sorry
if I look at the expectation so the
expectation of this guy is just the
expectation of one of them all right so
I just do expectation theta okay okay
the KL
remember the key L was expectation theta
log F theta divided by F so that's
between P theta and P theta Prime and
that's no sorry that's the true P and
let's call it f P theta right so that's
the that's what showed up which is
indeed equal to expect minus expectation
theta log F theta plus log of F which is
just a constant with respect to theta
alright this is the thing that's up
there it doesn't matter okay so this is
what shows up here and just the fact
that I have this 1 over N doesn't change
because they are IID now when I have
things that are not iid because what I
really had was y1 yn and y i at this a
density F theta I which is just the
conditional density given X I then I
could still write this and now when I
look at the expectation of this
I when I'm going to be left with is just
want to rent some from I equal one to n
of the expectation of log F theta I of Y
I okay and it's basically the same thing
except that I have a one over n
expectation in front and I didn't tell
you this because I only showed you what
the KL divergence was for between one
between two distributions but here I'm
telling you what the KL is between two
products of distributions that might
that are independent but not necessarily
identically distributed okay
that's what's gonna show up just because
it's a product of thinks that when you
have the log it's just gonna give us
some other questions all right so what
do we do here well as I said now we know
that the expectation of H is negative
Fisher information so rather than
putting H inverse in my iterates for
newton-raphson I just should I'm just
gonna put the inverse Fisher information
and remember I had a minus sign in front
so I'm just gonna pick up a plus sign
now just because I is negative the
expectation of the of the hessian and
this guy has essentially the same
convergence properties and it just
happens that it's easier to compute i
than HLN and that's it that's really why
you want to do this
now you might say that well if I use
more information I should do better
right but it's actually not necessarily
true for several reasons but let's say
that one is probably the fact that I did
not use more information every step when
I was computing this thing at XK I
actually pretended that at theta K the
true distribution was the one
distributed according to theta K and
that was not true this is only true at
when theta K becomes close to the truth
eita
and so in a way I what I gained I lost
again by making this this thing it's
just really a matter of simple
computation so let's just see it on a
particular example actually on this
example it's not gonna look much simpler
it's actually gonna be the same
alright so I'm gonna have the Bernalillo
example alright so we know that Burnley
belongs to the canonical exponential
family and essentially all I need to
tell you is what B is and B of theta for
bernoulli's log 1 plus e theta right we
computed that ok and so when I look at
my log likelihood it's going to look
like the sum from icon once you n why I
okay so here I'm gonna actually use the
canonical link so it's going to be X I
transpose beta minus log 1 plus
exponential X I transpose beta and Phi
for this guy is equal to 1 for everyone
what I did okay so this remember the the
the density right so that was really
just so the PMF was exponential y theta
minus log 1 plus e theta there was
actually no normalization that's just
the density of a vernal e and theta is
actually log P over 1 minus P and so
that's what actually gives me what my
since P is the expectation this is
actually giving me also my canonical
link which is the log in link we saw
that last time and so if I start taking
the log of this guy and summing over N
and replacing theta by X I transpose
beta which is the with the canonical
link tells me to do I get this guy out
there for everyone if it's not please
redo this step on your own
okay so I want to maximize this function
sorry so I want to maximize this
function over there on the first line as
a function of beta and so to do this I
want to use either newton-raphson or
what I call Fisher scoring so Fisher
scoring is the second one when you
replace the Hessian by negative Fisher
information alright so I replace these
two things and so I first take the
gradient okay so let's take the gradient
of a line so the gradient of L n is
gonna be you awesome so here this is of
the form Y I which is a scalar times a
vector X I beta that's what I erase from
here the derivative of B transpose X the
gradient of B transpose X is just B so
here I have just why I X I okay so
that's of the form Y I which is a scalar
times X I which is a vector now what
about this guy well here I have a
function so I'm gonna have just the
usual rule that the the chain rule right
so that's just going to be 1 over this
guy and then I need to find the Hessian
of this thing so the 1 is going away and
then I apply the chain rule again so yet
e of X I transpose beta and then the
Hessian of this thing which is X I okay
so my Hessian I can actually make
gradient sorry I can actually factor out
all my X eyes and it's going to look
like this
my gradient is a weighted average or we
did some of the excise this will always
happen when you have a canonical when
you have any generalized in your mouth
and that's pretty clear where did the
exercise show up whether it's from this
guy or that guy the X I came from the
fact that when I take the gradient of X
I transpose beta have this vector X I
that comes out it's always going to be
the thing that comes out so I will
always have something that looks like
some some with some weights here of the
excise now when I look at the second
derivative
so same thing I'm just going to take the
derivative this guy since nothing
depends on beta here here I'm just gonna
have to take the derivative of this
thing and so it's gonna be equal so if I
look now at the Hessian Ln as a function
of beta I'm gonna have some from I could
1 to N of well why I what is the
derivative of Y with respect to beta
well yeah
zero okay doesn't depend on beta
I mean its distribution does but Y
itself is just a it's just a number
right so this is zero so I'm gonna get
minus and then I'm gonna have again the
chain rule that shows up so I need to
find the derivative of x over 1 plus X
which is the derivative of x over 1 plus
X
ok so that's 1 over 1 plus X square so
that's minus 8x I transpose beta sorry
No 1 divided by 1 plus e x I transpose
beta squared times the derivative of the
exponential which is e X I transpose
beta and again X all right
and then I have this X I that shows up
but since I'm looking for a matrix I'm
going to have X I X I transpose right ok
so this is just I know I'm gonna need
something that looks like a matrix in
the end and so one way you want to think
about it is you know this is gonna spit
out the necks I there's already an X I
here so I need to so I'm gonna have
something that looks like X I and I'm
gonna have to multiply by another vector
X I and I wanted to form a matrix and so
what you need to do is to take an outer
product and that's it all right
so now well as a result the updating
rule is this honestly this is not a
result of anything I actually rewrote
everything that I had before with a
theta I replaced by beta because it's
just painful to rewrite this entire
thing put some big parentheses and put
minus one here okay and then I would
have to put the gradient which is this
thing here
so as you can imagine this is not super
nice actually what's interesting is you
know at some point I mentioned there's a
pseudo Newton method they're actually
doing exactly this they're saying oh I'm
actually at each iterations I'm actually
gonna just take those guys if I'm at
iteration K I'm actually just gonna sum
those guys up to K rather than going all
the way to end and look at every one so
you're just looking at your observations
one at a time based on where you were
before okay so you know you have a
matrix you need to invert it so if you
want to be able to invert it you need to
make sure that the sum with those
weights of X I outer x i' or xixi
transpose is invertible so that's a
condition that you need to have and well
I mean you don't have to because
technically only to invert you just need
to solve the linear system but that's
that's actually guaranteed in most of
the cases if n is large enough all right
so everybody sees what we're doing here
okay so now that's for the
newton-raphson if i wanted to actually
do the fisher scoring all i would need
to do is to replace the hessian here by
its expectation when i pretend that the
beta that i have a relation k is the
true one what is the expectation of this
thing
and when I say expectation here I'm
always talking about conditional
expectation of Y given X the only
distributions that matter that have
mattered in this entire chapter or
condition a conditional expectation of Y
given X the conditional expectation
of this thing given X is what its itself
it does not depend on why it only
depends on the X's so conditionally on X
this thing as far as we're concerned is
completely deterministic so it's
actually equal to its expectation and so
in this particular example there's no
difference between Fisher scoring and
newton-raphson and the reason is because
the gradient no longer depends on Y i
sorry the hessian no longer depends on Y
i okay
so this slide is just repeating some
stuff that I've said ok so I think this
is probably ok let's go through this
actual at some point I said that Newton
Rapson
you have a question not when you have a
canonical link no but okay so why I
times X I transpose beta so essentially
you know when I have a general family
what is referring to is that this is
just B of X I transpose beta so I'm
gonna take some derivatives and there's
gonna be something complicated coming
out of this but I'm certainly not gonna
have some why I showing up the only
place where Y I shows up is here now if
I take two derivatives this thing is
gone because it's linear so the first
one is gonna keep only this guy and the
second one is gonna make it go on the
only way this actually shows up is going
to have an H here and if I have an H
then I can take second derivatives and
this thing is not gonna be completely
independent of beta sorry yeah this
thing is still going to depend on beta
which means that this Y I term is not
going to disappear I believe we'll see
an example of that or maybe I removed
I'm not sure actually I think we all
right
so let us do it early we weighted least
squares or IR LS which I've actually
recently learned is a term that even
though is defining the 50s people still
feel free to use to define to call their
new algorithms which have nothing to do
with this this is really something where
you actually do intuitively we weighted
these course and so which means that
every step ok let's just actually go
through this quickly what is gonna be
iterative Lee we're weighted least
squares the way the steps that we had
here showed up let's say those guys X
star as this is when we were actually
solving this linear system right that
was the linear system when we're trying
to solve but solving a linear system can
be done by just trying to minimize right
if I have X a and B it's the same as
minimizing the norm of a X minus B
squared right over X right if I can
actually find an X for which is zero it
means that I've actually solved my
problem and so that means that this is
actually there's actually I can solve
linear systems by solving these problems
and least squares problems are things
that statisticians are comfortable
solving and so all I have to do is to
rephrase this as the least squares
problem okay and you know I could just
write it directly like this but there's
a way to streamline it a little bit and
that's actually by using that's actually
by using weights okay so I'll come in
the weights in this well not today
actually but very soon all right
so this is just a reminder of what we
had we have that why I give an X I as a
distribution distributed according to
some distribution in the canonical
exponential family so that means that
the log likelihood looks like this again
this does not matter to us this is the
form that matters and we have a bunch of
relationships that we actually spent
some time computing the first one is
that mu is B prime of theta I the second
one is that if
Zhu Jie of new I I get this systemic
component X I transpose B that's
modeling now if I look at the derivative
mu I with respect to theta I this is the
derivative of B prime of theta I with
respect to theta I so that's the second
derivative and if I'm gonna call it VI
if Phi is equal to 1 this is actually
the variance and then I have this
function H which allows me to bypass
altogether the existence of this
parameter mu which says if I want to go
from X I transpose beta all the way to
state I I have to first do G inverse and
then V prime inverse so I stopped here
we just have mu ok ok so now if I what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna apply the
chain rule and I'm gonna try to compute
the derivative of my likelihood
likelihood with respect to beta so again
the log likelihood is much nicer when I
read it as a function of theta than a
function of beta but it's basically what
we've been doing by hand you can write
it as a derivative with respect to theta
first and then multiply by the
derivative of theta with respect to beta
ok and we know that theta depends on
beta as H of X I transpose beta ok I
mean that's basically what we've been
doing for the the Bernoulli case we just
I mean we use the chain rule without
actually saying it but this is gonna be
convenient to actually make it
explicitly show up ok so when I first
take the derivative of my log likelihood
with respect to theta I'm gonna use the
fact that my canonical family is super
simple ok so what I have is that my log
likelihood L n is the sum from I equal 1
to N of why I theta I minus B of theta I
divided by Phi or some constant which I
will go with soon isn't gonna take my
first derivative so if I take the
derivative with respect to theta I of
this guy this is actually going to be
equal to Y I minus B prime theta I
divided by Phi
and then I need to multiply with the by
the derivative of theta I with respect
to beta and remember theta is H of X I
transpose beta so the derivative of
theta I with respect to beta J this is
equal to H prime of X I transpose beta
and then I have the derivative of this
guy actually let me just do the gradient
of theta I add beta right that's what we
did I'm just calling theta I I'm just
thinking of theta I as being a function
of theta so what should I add here I was
just a vector X I which is just the
chain rule again that's H prime right we
don't see it but there's a prime here
it's the derivative
okay we've done that without saying it
explicitly so now if I multiply those
two things I have this why I minus B
prime of theta I which I call by its
good name which is nu i ib prime of
theta I is the expectation of Y I
conditionally on X I and then I multiply
by this thing here so here this thing is
written coordinate by coordinate but I
can write it as a big vector when I
stack them together and so what I claim
is that this thing here is of the form Y
minus mu but here I put some tildes
because what I did is that I first I I
divided this I multiply everything by G
prime of mu for each mu okay so why not
okay so I actually free on this slide it
will make no sense why I do this
all right I basically multiply by G
prime on one side and divide by G prime
on the other side okay so what I write
so far is that the gradient of LM sorry
the gradient of Ln with respect to beta
is the sum from IQ one to end of Y I
minus mu I let's call it divided by Phi
times H prime of X I transpose beta X I
okay so I just stacked everything that's
here and now I'm gonna start calling
things the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna divide so this guy here I'm
gonna push here now this guy here I'm
actually going to multiply by G prime of
new I and this guy I'm going to divide
by G prime of new I so there's really
nothing that happened here
I just took G prime and multiply and
divide it by G prime why do I do this
well that's get actually going to be
clear when we talk about iteratively
really squares but now essentially I
have a new mu a nu Y which is so this
thing now is going to be Y tilde minus
mu tilde so I I now this guy here
I'm gonna call WI and and I have the X I
that's there which means that now the
thing that I have here I can write as
follows gradient Ln F beta is equal to
what well I'm going to write it in
matrix forms so I have the sum over I of
something multiplied by X I so I'm gonna
write it as X transpose then I'm gonna
have this matrix W 1 WN and then 0
elsewhere and then I'm gonna have my
white Zelda minus mu and remember X is
the matrix with a sorry it should be a
bit narrow I have N and then P and here
I have my X IJ and this matrix on row I
and column J and this is just a matrix
that has the W eyes on the diagonal and
then I have Y tilde minus mu so this is
just the matrix rewriting of this
formula all right so it's just saying
that if I look at the sum of weighted
things of my columns of X I
it's basically the same thing right when
I'm going to multiply this by my matrix
I'm gonna get exactly those terms right
why I minus mu I tilde times WI and then
when I actually take this X I transposed
time this guy I'm really just getting
the sum of the columns with the with the
weight right agree so if I look at this
thing here this is a vector that has as
14 8y i a WI times y I tilde minus mu I
children and I have n of them so when I
multiply x transpose by this guy I'm
just looking at a weighted sum of the
columns of X transpose which is a
weighted sum of the rows of X which are
exactly my x i's right and that's this
weighted sum of the x i's okay so here
as I said the fact that we decided to
put this G prime of MU I here and G
prime of MU I here we could have not
done this right we could have just said
this I call I don't even forget about
the cella just call it Y I minus mu I
and here I just put everything I don't
know into some WI and so why do I do
this well it's because when I actually
started looking at the Hessian and
what's gonna happen yeah I will do that
next time but let's just look quickly at
the outcome of the computation of my
Hessian so I compute a bunch of second
derivatives and here I have two terms
right well he's gone all right so I have
two terms and when I take the
expectation now it's gonna actually
change right this thing is actually
going to depend on Y I because I have an
H which is not the identity oh no you're
here sorry and so when I start looking
at the expectation so I look at the
conditional expectation given X I the
first term here has ayi minus
expectation so when I take the
conditional expectation this is going to
be 0 the first term is going away when I
take the conditional expectation but
this was actually gone already if we had
the canonical term because the sec
derivative of H when H is the identity
is 0 but if H is not the identity H
prime prime may not be 0 and so I need
that part to remove that term and so now
you know I work a little bit and I get
this term that's not very surprising in
the second derivative I see I have terms
in B Prime
I have term in H prime but Square and
then I have my X I outer X I X I X I
transpose which we know we would see
okay so we'll go through those things
next time but what I wanted to show you
is that now once I compute this I can
actually show that if I look at this
product that showed that Briah had B
prime prime time H H prime squared one
of those terms is actually 1 over G
prime and so I can rewrite it as one of
the H Prime's because I had a square
divided by G prime and now I have this X
I X I transpose so if I did not put the
X if I did not put the G Prime in the W
that I put here completely artificially
I would not be able to call this guy WI
which is exactly what it is from this
board and now that this guy is WI I can
actually write this thing here as X
transpose W X ok and that's why I really
wanted my W to have this G prime of MU I
in the denominator because now I can
actually write a term that depends on W
now you might say how do i reconcile
those two things what the hell are you
doing and what the hell I'm doing is
essentially that I'm saying that if you
write beta K according to the Fisher
scoring iterations you can actually
write it as just this term here which is
of the form X transpose X inverse X
transpose Y but where I actually
squeezed in this W's and that's actually
a weighted least squares and it's
applied to this particular guy so we'll
talk about those weighted least squares
but remember these squares is of the
form X beta hat is X transpose X inverse
X transpose Y and here is basically the
same thing except that I squeeze in some
W after my X transpose
okay so that's how we're gonna solve I
don't want to go into the details now
and because mostly because we're running
out of time are there any questions